أود الآن أن أحصل على بعض ردود الفعل ، ينضم إلي
الابن الأكبر لريفيكاريري بهريري
الآن وهو يعيش في لندن ،
هل يمكنك أن تعطينا
رد فعلك على هذا أه على هذا الحكم
الصادر عن المحكمة المدعومة من الأمم المتحدة في
هولندا ،
فقط فرد واحد أدين
في الاغتيال
أه بالنسبة لي إنه إغلاق إنها لحظة مؤلمة للغاية
أه أود أن أقدم أعمق التعازي
لجميع أفراد عائلتي إخوتي وأخواتي الذين
تعرفهم بعد 15 عامًا
للأسف كنت هناك عندما
حدث الاغتيال لذا فهي كلها ذكريات حية.
أنا راضٍ جداً عن التنبؤ
كما تعلم قالت المحكمة
بشكل خاص جداً أن الأمر لم
يحدث في
فراغ سياسي أه هذا أه الاغتيال
اغتيال سياسي
وكانوا واضحين جداً بتقديم أدلة غير مباشرة
على ذلك  أن
هذا البيان أه لذا أه نعم صحيح
أن
أه سالم عياشة كان أه كبير كما
يجب أن نؤكد أنه كان
عضوًا بارزًا في حزب الله
ونعم كذلك  هل أنت محبط على أي مستوى
لأنه من حيث
توجيه أصابع الاتهام
إلى حزب الله نفسه لم
يكن هناك أي
ارتباط أه لا يخدع
أن المحكمة لم تتوصل إلى
نتيجة مفادها أن حزب الله
نفسه كان وراء هذا الاغتيال ،
فأنت تعلم أن المحكمة  التفويض
شديد أه
أه واضح عليهم أن يبدوا
ما وراء ظل الشك أه
أن المتهم مذنب أه وأنت تعلم
في المحاكم نحتاج أن نحترم
ذلك كثيرا جدا